what's going on guys today i'm going to
be giving my honest thoughts on jiu
jitsu kaizen after finally catching up
with the manga
like a lot of you who are likely
watching this video i watched season one
as it was airing but i didn't really
feel the immediate need to start reading
the series
eventually i did get around to it and
the expectations i had going in were
blown away
as there were a ton of surprising twists
and just hard-hitting scenes
that make jiu-jitsu kaizen super
interesting in this video i'm going to
explain the elements of this series i
like and dislike without giving away any
spoilers
and hopefully after that you'll be more
inclined to read it yourself if you
haven't already
as usual don't forget to hit that sub
button and drop a like if you think i
should do more jiu-jitsu kaizen content
in the future
okay so the first thing i loved with the
characters themselves considering anyone
who's really relevant has a unique
personality
coupled with clear motivations that make
sense mkamara in particular was a great
side character
and the way things unfolded in regards
to him was probably one of my favorite
parts of the series
gojo's cockiness and general demeanor is
another highlight but the manga changed
how i perceived his importance
from season one you do understand that
he is the strongest sorcerer but the
manga just makes it clear how
rare his ability is and how he's
basically a once in a lifetime
phenomenon that basically holds
everything together
that's why his dream to reset jiu
jitsu's society makes perfect sense
since he wants to foster strong allies
who can one day fill the void and make
it so he's not holding everything on his
back
there are other characters like gojo who
have a similar threatening aura
in that whenever they're involved you
feel confident they're gonna win or at
least do serious damage to whoever
they're fighting
examples include yuta mojito tsukuna
obviously
all those guys have serious main
character energy and is usually an
entertaining time whenever they're
involved
sukuna in particular is really
intriguing to me because he very
obviously has an elaborate plan in place
going all the way back to when he made
that binding vow with yuji
yet even now it's still hard to piece
together what he's planning
there are a ton of other characters who
i think are great including chozo megumi
toto i mean there's just too many
and surprisingly you know chozo was one
who i didn't expect to like but as the
series progressed i did enjoy whenever i
saw him more and more
next up another good thing was how my
expectations were constantly being
subverted in a way that felt natural
normally when you reach a certain part
in a storyline you have a rough idea of
how things might go but akutami
frequently diverts from the
reasonable part as you might expect
there are also times when something
crazy looks like it's about to go down
and you think to yourself they're not
really gonna do this are they
and then no they actually do follow
through with it the power system is also
pretty great
and as we all know the best ability this
series has to offer is the variety of
domain expansions
this is something that many of the best
sorceress can't even use which makes it
all the more special when someone does
actually go and do it
because the person who creates the
domain is guaranteed to land a hit
one of the aspects of the manga i liked
was the different ways people tried to
survive this impossible situation
naturally gojo survived by simply
expanding his own domain but most people
don't exactly have that option so it was
interesting seeing the other techniques
to get around this
and also the crazy scene that happened
uh with a certain member
of the xenon family the power system
also ties into politics
given that certain cursing needs can
only be used by specific families
my opinion now is that the value placed
on certain techniques is actually
fascinating
because it means the power dynamics of
the big families can change with the
flip of a coin
people like narutoshi are the best
example of this as they're thought into
positions of power even when normally
they wouldn't be asked to do so
when we look at megumi specifically he
obviously has the best or most
valuable technique of the xenon family
and in recent chapters we saw how it can
be used to his political advantage
now the topic of death is something that
jujitsu kaizen deals with incredibly
well
as it's something you actually fear in
this series when it comes to the other
manga that i read on a weekly
basis once in a while a side character
might actually die but the characters we
actually like
are nearly always guaranteed to survive
jiu jitsu kaizen subverts that
expectation in a big way
as outside of gojo yuji and magumi i
genuinely think anyone else could be
killed at any moment
when we look back at jumbo for example
he was being set up like a major
character going forward
i mean in terms of importance i would
compare him to the caliber of someone
like todoroki when he first appeared in
my academia
someone like that doesn't just get
killed off and never seen again which is
why i was half expecting jumped to
return in some way
i didn't know how it was gonna happen i
didn't know when it was gonna happen but
i was fully expecting it for a long time
and uh yeah eventually i just came to
realize this is what this series is like
like people will really just die
in the manga there were further
casualties that are even more shocking
than this one
and what it means is that the big
battles have a lot of suspense
besides the three characters i mentioned
and obviously sukuna because he's you
know in yuji's body
um besides those guys i don't think
anyone is off the table when it comes to
being killed
last thing to mention that i liked is
the element of mystery including yuji's
heritage
and potential traces at jiu jitsu high i
wouldn't say these mysteries presented
are anything too radical
but it's definitely enough to keep you
invested the thing i'm most eager to
find out about is what sukuna wants with
megumi but i'm sure we'll find out once
his plan comes together
moving on to what i didn't like about
the series number one was that sometimes
the explanation for things was
unnecessarily complicated
whether it be specific curse techniques
or a certain event that happens after
the shibuya arc
i imagine there were just much easier
ways to convey the same point
number two although it is the minority
for certain fights it was hard to
decipher what was happening from panel
to panel
however i imagine the anime will
obviously make this a lot clearer
most of the time you can tell exactly
what's going on but yeah occasionally
you'll get panels where you have to like
study what's happening just to see if
you can decipher it and even then you
might not realize what it is
final point was that the relationship
between meimei and her brother was
something that was quite strange to me i
mean it's not the first time i've seen
something like this
but there was just one scene in
particular that took it too far in my
opinion
anyway guys those are my overall spoiler
free thoughts on jujitsu kaizen
let me know in the comments what you
think of this series and drop a like as
well as i do really appreciate it
until the next one peace out